should fight one another for the honor
of leadership and not everybody does
who's in charge
me yes happy comic-con a week everyone
we have the best possible news ever and
it's not even comic-con yet that doesn't
start till Wednesday Marvel just
confirmed that they've already started
work on Thor for given that they're
starting development of the movie after
the x-men deal and Fantastic Four deal
is done they can do as much Silver
Surfer as they want in this so post all
your best jokes about Marvel's remake a
Point Break in the comments down you
stock Point Break we all wondered if
they were gonna make it Chris Hemsworth
had made some comments it was a clip of
him talking about it recently so I'll
play that in a second but this is the
greatest possible way to start comic-con
week I'll be doing videos for everything
all week long so if you're brand new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
we've still got IMAX ticket giveaway
stuff going on I'll name a new winner at
the end of this so this is the clip of
Chris Hemsworth talking about Thor 4
right before Avengers end game came out
just saying yes I'm totally kind of come
back for Thor 4 you see if you're killed
it'll be your last but you don't know if
you're killed or not but if you're not
do you think you'll do another one
you look as far as this is sort of
Marvel's phase 3 wrapping up a
culmination of all that this journey
whether or not they go off and then
shoot other things I do prequels or
sequels or whatever they can do I mean
Loki my brothers come back nine times
guys just keep appearing so who knows
what's in store for anyone it may
personally it's the best fun I've ever
had and I'd be happy to do more if they
wanted me but
so they'd established early on the chris
hemsworth really liked the way that
they'd changed the Thor character with
thor ragnarok he loved working with
Taika Waititi he was a great director on
film if he watched the behind the scenes
for that thumb they have a lot of fun
making that tyka had said previously
that he would love to come back and do
more Marvel films when James Gunn left
guardians of the galaxy 3 last year a
lot of people were like Tycho would be
the perfect person to come take over for
him but then they rehired James Gunn so
it seemed like Tycho was just gonna ride
the bench of Marvel directors until they
got around to finding another project
for him because who knew when Thor was
going to happen then he was announced
for the Akira live-action movie that
they were doing everyone was really
happy about that they announced that he
was gonna be making an animated Flash
Gordon film separately everyone was like
well that makes sense because thor
ragnarok is sort of like Marvel's
version of Flash Gordon but those are
all separate films now in the news that
Marvel is announcing him as the director
of Thor 4 and he's also going to be
writing the movie they're saying that
he's working on that first before he
does those other movies so it's not like
they're announcing the movie and then we
see it four years later this is like a
two three-year turnaround at most pretty
sure that the movie won't shoot til next
year just because they're announcing
that he's starting work on the script
right now that usually winds up being at
least a six month process so between now
and the end of the year they were fine
what the story is going to be they
announced the cast and then they start
shooting next year for possible 2021
release usually takes him about a year
to get a movie out after they actually
start shooting it so in terms of Marvel
phase for scheduling timeline this would
be happening sometime after Black
Panther 2 because I believe the plan is
to release Black Panther 2 February 2021
for four would probably wind up being
another November movie for some reason
they really like releasing Thor movies
at the end of the year no complaining I
totally happy wherever they want to
release it also in this news release
where they're confirming what's going on
with Thor 4 they also confirm as
guardians of the galaxy action during
guardians of the galaxy vol 3
there's the teaser from the end of
Avengers endgame that implies that that
was going to happen we all kind of
speculated James Gunn recently came out
and said something about it I just did a
video about that a couple of days ago
where he's like no I'm not gonna call
guardians of the galaxy 3 as guardians
of the galaxy because before they
confirmed Thor 4 everybody just assumed
that this would be the big movie that
Chris Hemsworth would come back for when
he said he wanted to keep playing Thor
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe so when
we're talking about Thor for though
people like what's the villain going to
be what's the story going to be
obviously you should go without saying
spoiler warning for the spider-man far
from home post credit scene because we
need to talk about some heavy Marvel
phase 4 stuff that they were talking
about during that movie so at the end of
spider-man far from home Nick Fury is on
the sword Space Station from the comics
implying that Marvel phase 4 is gonna be
way more cosmic in nature now it makes
more sense that they're leading off with
Thor 4 because it's such a cosmic
character now that scene of him at the
end of Avengers endgame with Valkyrie
makes a lot more sense like why wouldn't
he be king Thor well because they're
moving things into outer space a new
Asgard is gonna stay on planet Earth for
now their number becoming book villains
and comic book story twists that they
haven't done yet but because tyka is
doing the story just like he did part of
the story for Thor Ragnarok
in Ragnarok was a very different version
of comic book marvel Ragnarok they also
did a very different version of Gore the
god butcher with hellas character they
changed her quite a bit from the comics
she was a bit of a combination of a
couple different characters including
Angela I get a lot of Angela questions
Angela is the lost sister of Thor but
that's basically what they did with the
hella character during Ragnarok the lost
sister quote-unquote I've done a couple
different videos about as guardians of
the galaxy guardians of the galaxy vol 3
but now it just seems to confirm that
they'll use that movie as a bridge for
him to put him wherever he's going to be
at the beginning of Thor 4 so obviously
they have to introduce Adam warlock
during guardians of the galaxy vol 3 4
needs to lose all that beer weight that
he's got on him so they make a lot of
jokes about what they're doing at the
end of Avengers endgame in this scene
but it just sounds like now he's only
going to be with the guardians for a
little while during guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 probably to help them out
with their super opie quote-unquote
antagonist Adam warlock until they can
turn him to the light side of the force
because biggest Adam warlock twist in
the comics is that you have the mages
but you also have Adam warlock the good
part of him based on the guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 post-credit scene it
implies that the sovereign are going to
hatch him as a villain to take down
destroy the guardians but a little bit
of speculation if they're going to cycle
the Guardians roster Adam warlock was a
member of the guardians of the galaxy
during annihilation conquest would it be
cool if they cycled the roster and put
warlock on the team for future Marvel
phase four appearances
star-lord lost all of his special cosmic
abilities when they killed or supposedly
killed ego the Living Planet so they
would definitely need an assistant
taking down someone as powerful as Adam
warlock I've also done a couple videos
speculating on beta ray bill appearing
in the Thor movies I figured that they
would try to introduce them in guardians
of the galaxy volume 3 but now that
they've announced Thor forth they might
save beta ray bill for that movie back
on theory we also need to consider
because James Gunn is doing Suicide
Squad before he does guardians of the
galaxy vol 3 is that Thor 4 could shoot
before guardians of the galaxy vol 3
meaning that all the as guardians of the
galaxy stuff would happen during Thor 4
instead of during guardians 3 they
haven't officially confirmed when
everything is coming out exactly so
we'll find out about that later this
weekend but I made a whole bunch of
Silver Surfer Point Break jokes at the
beginning of this video they could
totally introduce Silver Surfer in a
Thor movie they had a bunch of
crossovers when they first debuted
Silver Surfer in the comics just because
Thor has always been a really big cosmic
character in the comics as well as the
Marvel movies so if you want to
introduce some of those other Fox
characters like you introduced
spider-man during Captain America Civil
War introduce them in someone else's
film before they go off to their solo
film Silver Surfer would be a great
character to start off with and you
could use that as a slow path to
Galactus Thor versus Silver Surfer and
then Thor versus Galactus would be
awesome and hilarious at the same time
your Herald summons you another world
awaits
let it be done quickly fun fact to the
voice of Silver Surfer previously was
done by Laurence Fishburne Morpheus
himself who in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is playing giant man so
bringing things full circle again more
fantastic for people coming into the MCU
as different characters just like Chris
Evans Human Torch becoming Captain
America in Michael B Jordan Human Torch
becoming kill monger there's so many
alumni from previous Fox Marvel movies
in the MCU now maybe they can have some
fun with that with the multiverse in a
Secret Wars Avengers movie at some point
so everybody freaked out in the comments
and let me know what you want the story
of Thor for to be and which characters
you want them to introduce remember you
can pick from any one x-men Fantastic
Four because they are free and clear to
introduce any of those characters that
they want because they're announcing
this now at the beginning of the week
I'm also expecting them to talk about
this during their Marvel phase for Comic
Con panel and it's rumored that some of
the Avengers going to be coming back so
Chris Hemsworth himself might show up
during their Comic Con panel on Saturday
of course I'll do a video for whatever
it is that they drop any footage any
announcements so no worries now it makes
a little more sense why Chris Hemsworth
was posting this funny video of him and
Matt Damon the other day just because it
seems like now he's getting hyped up for
them to start talking about Thor 4 at
Comic Con this week
[Music]
I never said hog I wasn't cool
congratulations Kelby Rock you're the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video in congratulations because it
seems like you might get your wish
email me on the about page of my channel
so I can get your contact details while
you wait for everything click here for
my spider-man bar from home fantastic
for Easter Egg video and click here for
my spider-man far from home post credits
scene video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]